en direct jean pierre colombiès il est
porte-parole de l'union des policiers
nationaux indépendants
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france on a vu en quelques
débordements entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre ont éclaté parce que
c'était prévisible
bonjour si elle était totalement puisque
il me semble avoir entendu quelque part
sur une chaîne d'information dirait
qu'on attendait c'est au cours de cette
manifestation entre 300 et 400
perturbateurs donc à l'évidence il
semblerait qu'on ait pris même le temps
de les compter moi ce qui me surprend
c'est qu'il ya eu il ya quelques mois
une manifestation qui avait débordé un
peu dans les mêmes circonstances plus
que j'ai déjà des établissements
bancaires avaient été pris pour cible et
que la manifestation qui avait suivi
avait été bien mieux maîtrisé puisqu'on
avait neutralisé des débuts des cortèges
ces fameuses élément perturbateur donc
c'est un petit peu surprenant qu'une
fois de plus on assiste à ces scènes de
batailles rangées entre des black blocs
ou des agitateurs comme jeune d'entendre
qu'ils sont parfaitement identifiés ou
identifiables et que malgré tous la
situation dégénère j'espère que ce sera
pas systématique parce que
malheureusement les manifestations de ce
caractère là risquent de se multiplier
et si on en reste systématiquement à une
opposition des forces de l'ordre des
manifestations alors même et qui vient
des revendications d'ordre social
ce sera un petit peu un petit peu
embarrassant un petit peu embêtant
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que la
positionne allemand a mal été préparé
par la police touchant madame on la
police elle fait ce pourquoi les
défaites c'est à dire de de maintenir
l'ordre et dans la mesure du possible
d'éviter que ça ne dégénère beaucoup
plus on l'a dit répété vous savez celui
du pays n'est pas un syndicat c'est une
association de policiers indépendant
apolitique
or des syndicats et nous mettons
systématiquement en garde contre l'idée
de systématiquement créer des situations
tic qui amène cette cette colère et ses
débordements niveau des manifestations
nous l'avons dit répété également
des manifestations des gilet jaune la
réponse à ce mécontentement cette colère
qui est là qui est sous jacente qui date
maintenant qui dure depuis deux ans
environ a les politiques n est pas
uniquement sécuritaire et certainement
pas policière et c'est de ça dont il
faut sortir c'est de 2,7 de ce blocage
de discussions sociales et de cette
colère qui finalement ne trouve
d'expression que dans la rue et face à
des forces de l'ordre tout simplement
et de quels constats êtes vous parti
pour créer ce collectif était à ni le
pays ni est parti tout simplement près
des incidents de viry châtillon qui a
donné lieu à ce fameux procès dont dont
vous êtes fait le relais vous ai
d'autres et d'autres chaînes ne fasse
justement ah non pas une compréhension
mais un mécontentement des policiers de
la base dont je suis le porte parole qui
estimé ne pas être suffisamment bien
représenté que ce soit en termes
syndicale qu en termes politiques et ils
ont dénoncé ces policiers en colère ont
dénoncé le manque de moyens qui était le
leur le manque de considération et qui
continuent d'ailleurs rien on le voit au
quotidien quels que soient les annonces
faites par le gouvernement qui hérite il
faut le dire d'une désagrégation du
service public depuis une trentaine
d'années alors être tous les cas on va
parler du beauvau de la sécurité qu'est
ce que vous en avez retourné alors on a
eu l'occasion d'en encore de s'exprimer
notamment au travers de deux plateformes
sur le net d'articles qui ont été dont
vous étiez le relais d'ailleurs ça je
dois signer vous est même un des rares
médias qui est aussi qui s'en est fait
le relais où on enrôle a tout de suite
mis en avant fait le constat que ce
boulot de sécurité et était uniquement
une plateforme de communication du
gouvernement pour calmer la colère des
policiers
d'ailleurs ce bourreau arrivé au moment
où il ya la parution du livre blanc ou
le fin si c'est ça on ne voit pas
vraiment pas sûr pas de crédible ça peut
déboucher tout simplement
c'est à cet effet pour vous occuper les
uns et les autres à discuter de
problématiques déjà connu déjà
identifiés qui ont d'ailleurs fait
l'objet de publications ce soit au
niveau du sénat l'assemblée nationale
pour dire très globalement de
parlementaires au travail de
parlementaires ou constat il est clair
il est bien connu il est très simple à
identifier
est ce beauf de la sécurité à nos yeux
de syrte
bon à rien monsieur collomb vient samedi
de manifestation pour le 1er mai mais
avant c'était contre la loi de sécurité
globale quelle est votre position sur ce
texte et des lois contre la sécurité
globale mais y aurait beaucoup à dire
tout le monde s'est focalisée sur
l'article 24 de dons ont tourné un petit
peu perdues le le sens réel puisqu'il
s'agissait de d'interdire ou du moins de
réprimer un peu plus cher encore si t'es
pas vraiment tout à fait call usage des
images de policiers qui pourraient être
faites
on a d'ailleurs vu ce sur quoi ça peut
déboucher puisqu'on a eu des affichages
de sauvages de policiers dans des cités
images photographies de policiers pour
les stigmatiser
le projet de sécurité globale va bien au
delà puisque il veut pérenniser le
développement des polices municipales et
surtout le déploiement falana je dirais
la la pérennisation de l'emploi des
sociétés privées pour assurer la
sécurité des concitoyens
donc c'est quelque chose qui va très
très loin et qui s'inscrit dans un
véritable changement de société
vous savez la colère des policiers au
quotidien elle est réelle on parle là où
se stigmatisent sur la colère sociale
d'aidé gilet jaune et des manifestations
qui expriment leur mécontentement mais
je peux vous assurer que les policiers
de terrain aussi sont loin d'être
satisfait de ce à quoi ils assistent un
des interlocuteurs précédents parler de
la lutte du déficit et de la
réglementation des règlements
financières imposées par bruxelles
tout ça ça se répercute sur la mise à
niveau des moyens qui seraient
nécessaires pour qu'une police dite
républicaine reviennent dans de bonnes
conditions
dans les secteurs qui aujourd'hui sont
totalement désertifier en termes de
sécurité
donc les problématiques qui sont qui
sont évoqués par tout le monde
sociologues économistes et et autres
concernent tout autant des policiers je
dirais des policiers de base qui sont
une forme de prolétarien aussi de la
sécurité
donc faut pas s'imaginer que la police
vit sur une autre planète elle est
totalement concerné par les difficultés
que rencontrent beaucoup de manifestants
d'ailleurs présent ce que je regrette ce
que nous regrettons au niveau de
l'association c'est que ce débat social
fondamental très
important se limite se résume trop
souvent à des images comme celles qu'on
prend ce moment c'est à dire des
affrontements c'est là c'est pas ça du
tout quelque part je passais c'est bien
regrettable qu'on en soit uniquement à
ce débat limité à une opposition
citoyenneté police comme on l'a déjà
déjà dénoncé à plusieurs reprises et
même depuis depuis de nombreux mois
pourtant c'est difficile de nier qu
aujourd'hui il ya des problèmes entre
une certaine partie de la population est
la police française
justement la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est comment on en est arrivé là
on en arrive là parce que je rappelle
quand même qu'au moment des gilet jaune
on a assisté à des scènes de d'ultra
violence qui aurait pu être neutralisé
en quelques semaines il aurait suffit de
revenir sur la réforme qui avait
déclenché tout ça est au bout de quinze
jours c'était réglé
or on s'est installé dans une situation
d'une traversée d'opposition
systématique des forces de l'ordre aux
manifestants
avec je dirais des expressions de black
blocks que nous estimons nous qui aurait
pu être réglé beaucoup plus rapidement
que ce que ce qui a été quart puisque ça
n'a pas été du tout pris en compte comme
ça aurait dû serait dû l'être
et bien évidemment qui dit s'est passé
des choses qui sont totalement
regrettable mais on peut pas accepter
que qui est autant de blessés comme nous
l'avons vu et compris des blessés
également du côté des forces de l'ordre
on en était à compter ceux qui avaient
fait le plus de blessés dans un camp
comme dans l'autre
est-ce que ça c'est une vie républicaine
normal vous savez jusqu'à l'année des
manifestations violentes
il y en avait toujours sûrs avec les
agriculteurs les sidérurgistes et j'en
oublie de depuis des dizaines d'années
c'est monnaie courante mais jamais
jamais on n'avait atteint un tel niveau
de violence et 2 une telle haine anti
antipolis et nous ce que nous regrettons
c'est que on est laissé s'installer ce
climat d'opposition et de haine je suis
désolée la police française c'est pas ça
alors je reprendrai moment haine anti
police pourquoi justement cette haine
antipolis qui apparemment grandi depuis
quelques années mais parce que j'en ai
deux sociétés d'il ya quelques minutes
or on est dans une guerre de l'image
n'est dans une guerre de la
communication
on s'est focalisé sur des images et des
faits d'ultra violence
à dessein à loisir il ya eu une
surenchère d'image et puis de campagne
médiatique et politique pour limiter le
débat le débat social à ça à cette
opposition d'ultra violence et c'est
totalement contre-productif et ça on ne
peut que le dénoncer et je vous dit on à
l'association du pays et avant son temps
certains policiers en colère l'ont dit
haut et fort il faut sortir de ça la
police républicaine n'est pas là pour
casser du manifestant
elle est là aussi pour assurer la
sécurité du plus grand nombre
la sécurité du citoyen gardiens de la
paix le mot gardiens de la paix ça a un
sens et il semblerait que ce
gouvernement est un tout petit peu perdu
de vue donc pour nous cette haine
antipolis est totalement investi c'est
aujourd'hui mais surtout elle et elle
est injustifiée et c'est presque à se
demander de savoir qui s'arrange dans
l'histoire parce que dans le même temps
on a réduit considérablement les
effectifs de police il ya une
désertification pas simplement des
médecins mais aussi des forces de
l'ordre dans certaines communes dans
certaines circonscriptions dans certains
quartiers il n'y a plus un seul policier
et j'ai envie de dire plus globalement
plus un seul représentant de l'état et
ça c'est fondamental
je reviens sur ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure sur la réduction des déficits
dès lors que l'état a pris parti de
réduire au maximum les dépenses de
l'état se répercute sur le personnel
soignant puisque en gros quand on recule
de moins en moins de personnel soignant
et les fonctionnaires de police et aussi
la justice si vous interrogez des
représentants d'organisations syndicales
de membres du personnel judiciaire vous
allez vite vous rendre compte qu'on
manque de tout de greffiers de certains
magistrats et puis d'une certaine
fluidité dans l'organisation du travail
donc ça n'est pas lié seulement à la
police c'est globalement une offensive
anti service public a débuté il ya
maintenant une trentaine d'années et qui
vint vers le décalage des pouvoirs
régaliens vers des systèmes de
on peut dire où aller pour simplifier
les choses des systèmes privés qui tombe
à 500 signalements la tension est
retombée
écoutez tant mieux mais vous savez ce
que les témoignages qui viennent de
passer sur votre antenne révèle une
chose une chose importante c'est qu'il
est il est fondamental est urgent que
des interlocuteurs sociaux c'est-à-dire
des dirigeants syndicaux des
représentants politiques s'expriment et
s'exprime beaucoup plus fort et ça
éviterait de la sorte à ce que les
débats aient lieu que dans la rue il
lâcha pas échappé à personne que le
parlement aujourd'hui témoigne d'un
démontre un encéphalogramme plat ce qui
est tout à fait regrettable c'est pour
ça qu'on en arrive là c'est pour ça que
c'est la rue qui finalement s'exprime
c'est pour ça que les gilet jaune sont
descendus dans la rue c'est resté quand
même ça dure et quand même quasiment
depuis presqu'un an voire plus même tout
simplement parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
relais il n'y a pas de rené d'expression
politique
et c'est particulièrement navrant il
faudrait pas que co lead servent
justement de paravent à tout débat
social tout débat politique
il a échappé à personne que pendant que
nous étions masqué est confiné des
réformes de travail sur les réformes
vont continuer et elles sont aujourd'hui
en phase d'être appliquée donc si on ne
veut pas que la rue c'est que ça explose
purement et simplement
il est urgent de revenir à un débat
démocratique sain il ne pas laisser
simplement les oppositions quelle
qu'elle soit face à des régiments de crs
de gardes mobiles et de policiers ont
tous genres c'est pas comme ça que ça
doit fonctionner le débat doit pas se
limiter cette opposition systématique
des boucliers contre les manifestants ce
ça n'a strictement aucun sens on a
aujourd'hui un débat qui serait biaisée
selon vous mais complètement vous en
avez la démonstration je dirais semaine
après semaine ce qui a été dit et tu
étais tout à fait vrai il y a des
propositions de loi qu'ils n'ont ni
queue ni tête je pensais à la loi
justement enfin aux propositions qui ont
été faites après l'assassinât de
rambouillet sur la lutte antiterroriste
on se demande qui cogite ses lois
l'interception des url tous azimuts
le suivi des terroristes psycho
judiciaire peut qu'ils feraient rire un
cheval de bois je veux sur l'oubli quand
même que les policiers globalement sont
aujourd'hui devenus une cible un
exutoire à toutes les oppositions et ça
et ça ça n'est absolument pas normal il
faut vraiment sortir delà de ça il ya un
débat qui doit être élargi aujourd'hui
bruxelles x dicté sa loi à la france et
dans tous les domaines dans tous les
registres que ce soit sécuritaire
médical ou même au niveau de la justice
tant qu'on ne sera pas sorti de ce
paradigme on ans on n'avancera pas j'ai
le logiciel des mannequins de maquereaux
et de son gouvernement n'a rien à voir
avec ce que revendique que la grande
majorité de la population française
qu'on a aujourd'hui masquer sa est ce
que vous imaginez simplement si on
revenait simplement sur débat sur les
masques enfin faut quand même pas
oublier que les plus grande autorité
morale et politique de ce pays ont dit
que c'était parfaitement inutile je
rappelle quand même les legs des paroles
2 de jérôme salle au monde de demain à
busan d'olivier verone 2 6 bat n'diaye
et jean louis et des meilleurs qui n'ont
eu de cesse que de le rappeler que
c'était inutile alors qu'on savait que
c'est enfin on sait aujourd'hui on l'a
su très vite qu'ils avaient tout
simplement un déficit dans la gestion
des stocks ce qui se passe tout
simplement c'est que nous vivons dans un
état qui ment en permanence comment
voulez vous qu'il existe une confiance
réciproque entre la majorité de la
population et l'état et il ne faudrait
pas il ne faut pas veinard
malheureusement c'est ce que nous
constatons c'est que devant cet
imbroglio de de discours et de décision
on limite le débat sur quoi nous
assistons c'est à dire des manifestants
contre des boucliers
il ya véritablement un changement
d'attitude qui doit s'opérer jeudi à la
tribune des militaires on est un des
plus beaux exemples mais on n'a jamais
vu ça alors pour dénaturer le propos on
compare cela aux putschistes de 1962
c'est là encore c'est risible
il ya un vrai malaise un malaise profond
entre même les représentants de de ceux
qui sont supposés assurer la pérennité
de l'état et vous savez moi ce que je
regrette en tant que représentant d'une
association or syndicale c'est que les
syndicats eux aussi restent en deçà de
ce débat parce qu'ils sont en train de
scier la branche sur laquelle ils sont
assis tout simplement en ne défendant
pas de service public qui les a nourris
pour
dans bien des cas ils feraient mieux de
se battre contre pour la pérennité de ce
qui a été acquis comme s'était dit
préalablement par le conseil national de
la résistance et parce que nous pouvons
appeler la république sociale terme
qu'on a oublié et qu'on peut rappeler en
cet anniversaire de la commune y reste
jean-pierre columbia sans manifestation
tania crise sanitaire alors que la
campagne vaccinale est censé s'accélérer
justement au niveau de la vaccination
sans nez du côté de la police est ce que
vous êtes là prioritaire aujourd'hui
dont les parts prioritaires tout le
monde se débrouille comme il le peut se
fait vacciner je dirais parfois un peu
accident si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
chacun se débrouille il est clair que
tant qu'on n'a pas développé des
vaccinations globale et générale au
niveau de toutes les strates de la
population
on n'en sortira pas ou du moins un mois
ça arrange peut-être quelqu'un ce qu'on
n'en sortent pas je veux dire vouloir
maintenir les gens dans une sorte de
crainte de contamination généralisée
c'est aussi une façon je dirais détourné
d'empêcher les grands manèges les grands
rassemblements les grandes
manifestations puis on va pas tout le
temps quelle société veut tourner
société perpétuellement masqué est
confiné parce que une année c'est
aujourd'hui on nous parle du variant
indien la semaine prochaine ce sera le
guatémaltèque
l'année d'après celui d'indonésie enfin
c'est pas sérieux on ne peut pas non
plus vivre en permanence dans la terreur
d'une contamination et surtout quand on
sait que le gros problème de ce pays
aujourd'hui c'est l'incapacité du moins
dans l'incapacité pas humaine mais
l'incapacité structurelle du système
médical à gérer cette crise on sait très
bien que les places de d'hôpitaux sont
limitées et qu'on continue par ailleurs
les restructurations hospitalières où on
est justement la possibilité donnée aux
médecins de soigner
enfin c'est pas sérieux on nous a appris
que le couple présidentiel avait été
soigné au moment de sa de sa
contamination par locaux vides je pose
une question très simple
par quoi par quel par quel moyen par
quel médicament ce couple a été soignée
tout simplement et c'est une réponse
qu'on n'a pas eu puisque le porte parole
du gouvernement lui-même a dit que
c'était par discrétion par le respect de
la vie privée du secret médical dans le
désert ou quoi la personne président
ancien de l'ua
tiens pas il est chef d'un état on doit
savoir parce que justement on a
suffisamment fait le reproche à ses
prédécesseurs comme pompidou où françois
mitterrand est une idée dans
l'obligation de communiquer sur la façon
dont il a été soigné je pense que des
millions de français seraient bien
intéresser bien curieux de savoir quels
médicaments leur a permis de s'en sortir
aussi bien jean-pierre columbia ce merci
d'être resté avec moi je rappelle que
vous êtes porte parole de l'union des
policiers nationaux indépendants merci à
vous